مواجهه البرهان واحمد العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوات
احمدتي على السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمدتي اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حملتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
تراشق كلامي يستكمله احمد
العطف لكنه يؤكد ايضا ان البرهان لن يتوقف
فيما يتهم قائد الجيش قوه احمد تي باعمال
نهب في الخرطوم ودارفور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات